it's called bitter and better and the
only difference between bitter and
better is the eye in it
i knew jerry falwell was was pulling
something i just didn't know what are
you championing
yeah hi
i'm a wild gal
we had a theme of our show and a theme
of our show
on ptl was you can make it and i am a
you can make it person and i just
believe that anybody can make it and if
they the bible says that when you fall
down you'll rise again and i believe we
might have fallen down but we're gonna
rise again
[Music]
we don't know what the future holds
but i can assure you jim and tammy
someday
will be helping people again
[Music]
well you know the people that stole ptl
literally
a con game was
perpetrated to jim and tammy these
people wouldn't even allow me to go back
to clean my own desk out and so
we're you know it's a strange thing to
be cut off
from something you built we've been like
people without a country since this has
happened we didn't read the papers but
occasionally it just intrigues me so
much that i have to buy and i know why
they get people to buy it now because i
bought it i bought it myself to find out
what i had done and i would read these
things and i would i
no basis for him jim and tammy to open
healing shrine in arkansas
we had no plans to open a healing trunk
i raised a chicken from the dead night
i'm scared to death of chickens the only
chicken i get near is kentucky fried
i understand they sell some was it two
billion dollars worth of chicken
our sales this year will exceed two
billion yes
i mean it was a they put we're on comedy
shows in fact we were on uh what was
that show with the gals down one of my
favorite programs the oh yeah the the
gals out in florida hey just because you
put your makeup on with a butter knife
doesn't make your tommy baker
i just laugh with it i think it's fun
it's fun everybody else laughs and i
laugh too that's okay
i just want our partners to know
we have repented
and we need their emotional
and financial support now more than ever
i went down to the garment district the
other day and i saw and a group of young
people happened to see me and hi tammy
you know start screaming and i imagine
before that little session was over i
had probably signed 50
60 autographs i mean i signed hands i
signed shopping bags i signed little
pieces of paper i signed anywhere
anything you could sign i think we
signed it we've always
had a heart for hurting people but until
you've hurt this bad yourself
you never really know that every single
day when they get up it's another day to
hurt all day long god help us
god speak to you
god loose these finances in the name of
jesus
i want to die i in fact
for months and months and months
every hour of the day that's all i could
think about is dying and praying to die
the hurt the pain was beyond
what i could say in these few minutes on
this program it's just it's beyond
comprehension
and the hurt
of of uh being totally smeared and
destroyed well i have two little words
robert that i minister about in prison
it's called bitter and better and the
only difference between bitter and
better is the eye in it
jim and tammy faye baker and the
continuing saga of the ptl club have
taken on the irresistible dimensions of
a national soap opera you know the
scriptures say that you're not to
defend yourself
and you're supposed to let god defend
you and so we were sitting back
you know praying
talking to our minister friends
reading the bible waiting for god to
defend us and so
the thing kept going on and on and on
it is in its own way as awful as
fascinating and as impossible to ignore
as a gigantic traffic accident and i
talked to some of my minister friends
and they finally said jim we think you
ought to you ought to go out
and we picked ted cobble because we felt
that it was live the money went into
a lot of buildings buildings and yeah
and
and the pay for our air time and the
light bill and your bonuses and your
salaries and the bonuses of i mean for
example well we felt he was a fair man
we felt so that's that's the reason we
did that because we don't mind hard
questions rob that's not it the truth is
the truth and so you know we're willing
to tell the truth no matter how hard the
questions are
i think it'd be fun to do commercials
and i think the makeup companies are
losing a big thing by not asking me to
do commercials for their makeup
and and so i hope to we we both hope to
get back on television and do what what
we feel god has called us to do do you
find any openings for
leading our news is jim baker's fall
from grace the former tv preacher has
plummeted from bright lights and luxury
to the bare four walls of a jail cell i
don't think he was treated fairly i
think jim had too much power the last
year we were at heritage usa six million
people came through the gates i think
the government got nervous one person
being able to
draw that many people and there plus
there were millions and millions that
watched the ptl television network the
now bankrupt and closed ptl vacation
resort stands as a reminder of the
bizarre mushrooming scandal that ranked
the multi-billion dollar religious
broadcasting industry
setting off the bitter 1987 holy wars
among television evangelists i think
they set out to get jim through jerry
falwell
because i asked jim not to sign heritage
usa over to jerry falwell
i felt in my spirit it was the wrong
thing to do
and i knew in my spirit like many women
do we call it a sixth answer
or uh intuition i knew jerry falwell was
was pulling something i just didn't know
what but i think he was a victim of his
own fear more than anything because it
could not have happened had not they
frightened him to the point
of just giving up but we are friends and
we can talk and i think that's very nice
and i i wish all divorces could be like
that why not you know why fight and be
bitter and be cruel to one another that
does nothing for anyone
i had colon cancer and the only thing it
is doing to me is making me very sad and
very nervous at this point i do trust
god and so god helps me give it gives me
a
peace to trust in god
knowing that all things do work together
for good and that god does care about us
and knows the situation we're in i feel
very very good and i'm here to tell
people today don't be afraid of cancer
it doesn't have to beat you you can be
dead but you've got to keep the right
attitude and you've got to keep a happy
spirit keep those endorphins building up
the immune system
drew
you remember mrs boback mimi's mother
call me tammy well i'm mimi's mom which
i think is fun because somebody finally
cast me right i took advantage of all
this makeup for once smart don't you
think
you must be mimi's mom that's right how
did you know
well
i think it's the eyes
i can't understand what did we do i do a
documentary about something that is so
painful why go back i was very grateful
to be able to tell my side
and
have the other side shown too and let
the give the people a chance to make up
their mind because the american people
are intelligent instead of languishing
in the desert tammy decided to get back
in front of the cameras so you've never
done pictures without those eyelashes no
and i never will because that's my
trademark and the wonderful thing for me
about doing the documentary was the fact
that there are two sides to every story
and so many times the public are
they don't make up their own minds they
just take the
side of what they read and they don't
realize that there's another side i hope
that they will come away from the
documentary at least giving me a chance
at least saying they're saying
maybe
maybe maybe it was different than we
thought when you get my age and when
you've been through the
life the way i have nothing really
shocks you anymore you sort of become
shock proof
you know i went through things that
would have killed a lot of people
and could have killed me had i not had
my faith in god and had a good firm
foundation under me i got on a little
pill called ativan and i initially i
used the little pill to fly with
and have to fly with
i mean on airplanes
and what it would do it just settled my
tummy down you know
and uh and as things got uh
progressively uh busier and busier at
heritage usa the last year we were there
i began to get have hyperventilation
problems and i found that that little
ativan would calm down that
hyperventilation but what i didn't
realize was that ativan has an afterlife
and it builds up and builds up in you
until when you take one you're actually
you actually have the remnants of of
other pills that are in you and i was
unable to get rid of the habit by myself
and so
i went to betty ford for help it was a
very low point for me because
to admit that you're addicted to
something
i didn't think i had an addictive type
of personality i'm just so grateful i
made it
you know there's a saying you can't go
forward looking in the rearview mirror i
think i'm
older and wiser
um
i'm more careful more cautious
i've always been an outgoing person my
life was wide open to everyone i i
trusted everyone i loved everyone and i
was and
i'm much more careful these days
i love to laugh i love to have fun and i
don't take anything too seriously i
think if you don't laugh over things
you'll cry
and i'm a person full of laughter
got it
get it got it good
okay honey
you